all right microsoft have said their
piece that's the first press conference
of the week done and dusted and we got a
bunch of video games to go through
it seems like a lot of our predictions
were correct they did focus on games and
they didn't talk about a lot of stuff
that we mentioned as well yeah
and there's little initial feelings
coming out of it uh sort of excited i
was expecting something a little bigger
it's nice to see the platinum game stuff
yeah okay yeah very excited a lot of
japanese uh creators making games that i
didn't really expect and that that gets
me really excited sean yeah i don't
think we got that huge third party
exclusive that we were hoping for um
platinum is obviously cool and
everything uh and i'm excited about it
but i mean we didn't get anything like
truly blockbuster it wasn't like the
metallica stuff last year yeah
all right let's let's go through them
one by one first of all uh call of duty
advanced warfare a kind of known
quantity we saw the start of that game
what are your initial feelings on that
one sean it looks good i mean the tech
in that game looks really neat like the
heat seeking grenade was probably my
favorite bit of that uh game it still
had those call of duty moments where the
guy had his arm trapped and you're just
you're just forced to sit there and
watch the story unfold whether you like
it or not um but there's some cool tech
i'm curious how much you can use that
throughout the game yeah pretty too
right yeah yeah it'd look good 60 frames
a second look really pretty i mean
there's lots of depth of field stuff
like yeah all right there was a shield
the shield that dropped down there was
the sonic shotgun there was a grenades
the homing grenades yeah those were
quite cool actually
all right there's a radar grenade as
well yeah it looks quite you know you
could say it looks quite titanfally
yeah i mean at least in the sense that
it was very sci-fi very futuristic tech
and it did establish a trajectory during
this press conference of severed limbs
yes exactly
yeah got some quick four action going on
there okay let's keep on going forza
horizon 2 you're a big fan of the series
sean what anything you knew you saw in
there it looks pretty looks good um
aside from that weather effects look
like they should be cool um a lot of the
same cars that we've seen in forza 5 but
mclaren p1 was obviously a signature car
um yeah no i'm i'm excited uh it also
looked like they said they announced the
uh nurburgring for forza four i guess
what's a five i'm sorry four to five
yeah and if you want to read a 2 000
word feature about the technology of
their track scanning you can do that on
gamespot.com because i wrote it
awesome and moving right along evolve
got a nice little bit of a trailer in
there as well was that a kraken yeah i
think so yes man
that game is looking awesome okay like i
really want to play that i mean i have
played that game actually thinking about
it but i want to play it with all the
new monsters i want to see that stuff
and it's interesting that uh xbox is
getting uh timed exclusive yes on the
dlc and it's definitely getting uh
exclusive on the beta as well i believe
i'm not sure if that's time both are
coming to xbox one first i think that is
a game that will benefit from having a
beta a lot by having it in people's
hands and speaking of uh
exclusives on the dlc front assassin's
creed unity
we saw the first bit of gameplay of that
they also touted that there would be
times exclusive dlc uh what's your first
take on that one sean or peter
oh yeah uh well i thought the co-op
looked really great i mean apart from
the whole time exclusive stuff whatever
the co-op and that looked really funny
and i actually like the setting of the
french revolution uh i mean obviously
it's fitting in sort of you know the
european like different timelines and
such but yeah the co-op looked really
interesting
the one thing i got away from it is that
it the original assassin's creed was
very much a you spend you know a couple
of hours trying to kill one person in
this they just it was four people
butchering the [ __ ] out of everywhere
everyone must die i mean what's left
after this right they killed everybody i
mean i really hope that's just what this
particular mission was and there's other
kind of traditional assassin's creed
stuff my question is four player co-op
how does that influence the free roaming
of the game because i'm somebody who
gets easily distracted and i see
something shiny in the distance i'm like
i'm gonna check that out screw you guys
yeah the map looks really cool it's uh
it is 1789 so it's right before the
revolution uh very lame is going on
there
again yeah very pretty and then severed
heads um yeah as well yeah it's gonna be
interesting to see more of this um i
feel uh next up on the list dragon age
inquisition and we saw a bit of any
dragon age fans here
i loved the first game in the series the
second one was so repetitive and so
small in scale that it kind of turned me
off but it seems like they're they're
coming back to like a big open-ended
style sandbox game yeah that looks looks
pretty good yeah it looks really pretty
as well again i mean it's interesting
that you know we didn't maybe we didn't
get the big next-gen moment however it
is noticeable with a lot of games on
this press conference how much better
they're looking when they're just sort
of you can tell people are getting
better with the hardware and we're going
to get more out of it and yeah they're
looking at at least if this is all real
time for us yeah most of this looks like
the sort of um like the the in-engine
conversational stuff they sort of have
yeah every now and again uh then we got
to see sunset overdrive what looked like
in maybe some sort of i thought is this
battlefield hardline
i was like
genuinely impressed by this because you
know the first time i saw this i was
like okay what but um actually having
seen the game in action it looks amazing
it's so bright and so colorful and like
it just looks like so much fun it's like
it's a bit like team fortress i guess in
the sense that you know it's a bit
tongue-in-cheek it kind of you know you
don't take it too seriously and i just
love it i think the action looks
fantastic you know i got a massive jet
set radio vibe from it as well like all
the grinding constantly like that looks
really fun and i like the way that it's
just every little like aspect of the
world sort of has part of that yeah yeah
sean what do you think about it i think
it looks really cool i mean i was a
little turned off from some of the
previous stuff they've been showing
because it's just
so so hyper stylized yeah but it seems
like it's still whether or not you
appreciate that it's still a super fun
game i feel like the attitude of it is a
little bit jarring like it's a little
bit 90s teenager but you know it is a
bit like gnarly dude yes it was a
terrible terrible accident i liked it
yeah you're into it oh yeah uh that's
coming october 28th i'm not sure if that
was a confirmed date beforehand but uh
they said it on the end of the trailer
then something came completely out of
left field which was i'm gonna i'm gonna
uh
let let you try and take this one peter
sure yeah i mean so capcom is notorious
like for kind of ignoring a lot of their
legacy franchises that fans really want
and this is the most self-aware
just like the best thing they could have
done for their fans i think like i had
some interest in dead rising three but
after seeing this i mean sure a lot of
it's like you know steeped in nostalgia
but my god dude like when they when they
brought up the zombie uh m bison that
gigantic guy yeah just
yeah i missed this earlier because i had
to run to the bathroom and i'm just
watching it
right now
it's so great yeah live reaction to this
sean what do you think oh hagar hagar so
good he just did he do a pile driver on
a nuclear bomb
i mean they're referencing captain
commando they're referencing rival
schools as well power stones background
dark stalkers dino crisis i mean
everything is in here
it's just
yeah wait till you see the title at the
end we should just let this play out
because this is this is pretty great
super dead rising three super ultra
arcade remix hyper edition ex plus alpha
dash
they've thrown that dash yet
yeah
and tofu of course from resident evil
commando man yeah yeah who knew it's
available today too yeah that's so crazy
the screw this e3 nonsense let's just go
play that right now yeah we saw fantasia
music involved for a second uh i i said
that maybe they might stick those guys
out there for two minutes
it's kind of what happened
fantasia you know i played that last
year um it was really fun and that was
one of the few like the only connect
games sorry i was looking forward to it
yeah it's actually pretty good but you
know dance century yeah fantasia done
and also
worth mentioning quickly that alex
mentioned that uh dance central
spotlight which is the new digital only
um
package that's coming out in september
uh will be in xbox one exclusive i'm not
sure if you went into details on that
word on the street is that's going to be
some sort of almost free to play model
where you get a bunch of songs at the
start and then you purchase other ones
yeah
we'll hear more at that fable legends
moving on anyone interested in fable at
all i had completely written that game
off earlier because i thought it was
just going to like abandon the humor and
the story of the fable series for just
straight up dungeon crawling but i'm
happy to see that it still seems to have
some sort of sense of personality and
character to it um i thought i was
actually pleasantly surprised by this it
didn't floor me but i thought it looked
pretty good and of course has the
four-player co-op but then you can also
play as the um enemy in the game as well
if you want to from almost like a
dungeon keepers this four player co-op
thing like seriously okay every game
though four player card four player card
i mean it's cool right and i like four
player co-op but it just seems like
that's that's the one thing we're gonna
get now from every press conference
borderlands sold a lot of coffee yeah
right moving on from that project spark
another game that we saw last year uh
they sort of leaned into a little bit
this is looking more and more to me like
they're trying to go for the minecraft
audience like they're they're leaning
into that yeah absolutely
it would make sense for them to do that
i mean the big thing from uh from this
was uh mr conker the squirrel oh so they
teased so like so if you don't know
conquer the squirrel is one of rare's
very old mascots who was a bit dirty he
was basically an alcoholic squirrel
and uh they sort of showed him on screen
everyone thought oh my god you conquered
the school game turns out he's just a
character you can put into projects for
yeah absolutely so because this was like
oh this is this is a rare franchise yeah
right yeah it's a rare franchise so we
didn't get a rare franchise edited today
no no so i guess they showed some more
killer instincts stuff which technically
belongs to where it was there but not
anymore yeah
that's what you get okay i think this
was one of the few glaring missteps of
the press conference yes were they just
completely underestimated how people
would react to that type of franchise
yeah there was a lusty booing yeah
yeah we're gonna go to a break we'll be
back in that just over 30 seconds with
all of the new ip that they announced
including the new team tomb raider
inside along with the rest of the stuff
that they talked about from the 2014
slate so stay there we'll be back in a
minute welcome back to gamespot's post
microsoft e3 press conference
impressions uh let's get straight back
to the games ori and the blind forest
peter what'd you think of this bad boy i
really like the tone that this game said
in the beginning you know it had a bit
of a uh like i want to say a miyazaki
feel to it it kind of reminded myself
and sean of dusty elysian trail um
i'm a little bit worried that the
gameplay won't necessarily be as
interesting because what they showed
seemed rather
simple yeah right and that's that's fine
but
but you know at the end of the day if
this game is all looks and no substance
what are we left with yeah a cartoon so
it'll be interesting to see if they lean
too heavy on there on their graphics or
not for the style rather and next one up
sean i want to ask you about this one
hello the master chief collection was
finally confirmed 100 maps halo 1 to 4
1080 60 frames per second arbiter's
voice
why what do you think about this bad boy
i had to you asked me about this in the
pre-show and i had to kind of tiptoe
around it because i actually saw already
demo the game like a month ago and it
was embargoed until they announced it
but it's essentially like listening to
your favorite band's bat catalog on
shuffle right it's got all four games uh
you can create these playlists for like
campaign missions and stuff so you can
do like all warthog missions or you can
do yeah you can do like multiplayer
where you're choosing whether to play a
halo 2 game mode next or a halo 3 game
mode next and it's all just up to the
group so it kind of like it takes all
the games it just jumbles them together
in a really interesting way
and i think that's kind of what i was
teasing before the show is that it's
more than just halo 2 anniversary it's
all four
and it's there's a lot of content there
on one disc this is a scene from halo 2
i think isn't it so they redid all the
cinematics wow for halo 2.
yeah so it's getting the full
anniversary yeah if you look at my story
on the site you'll see a super detailed
view of sergeant johnson and never has
that stubble looks so good
let me tell you uh this is coming
exclusively to xbox one on november 11th
um so yeah do you think this is going to
be something that would like sell units
mark um you know what
the difficulty is i'm not the biggest
halo fan however i know how big that
franchise is it is huge and i know
people are going to want to go back and
play those old games so you know what
yeah i'm gonna go out on the limb and
say it will sell a few more consoles and
of course it's got the uh the halo 5
guardians uh
beta bundled into that as well that'll
sell plenty of copies on your own right
and it's gonna have access to the ridley
scott halo series halo nightfall okay
yeah so that you definitely get some
content out of it there's a bunch of
packages there awesome okay so that was
the point at which the conference they
decided to say we're done with what's
coming out this year it was all known
quantities really as you'd expect
considering we're halfway through the
year and then they sit on what's
everything that's going to come out in
2015. and the first one that came on was
uh
kind of showed the hand early with
wearing this limbo shirt
but it was a game called inside which is
from the studio that made limbo yeah
mark what do you think of how how that
looked it looked really cool actually i
mean look limbo was one of my favorite
games on the airsports 360. so you know
i was really keen to see something more
from those guys and i'm glad they rolled
that one out what'd you think of it
peter played ed's new
it definitely reminded me of a game from
the 16-bit era called another world oh
yeah
flashback but yeah very similar in terms
of the uh you know like the atmosphere a
little bit and uh
that for me is sort of like a really big
incentive to want to play this they see
the perspective stuff seem to be used a
lot more on this because obviously the
thing about limbo is that it is
so 2d like it's 2d but it's like
incredibly 2d because of the the
monochromatic
art style whereas in this the way the
camera is sort of moving around with it
when they were like looking at that
shadowy figure walking through the door
uh look pretty cool and i've obviously
this is 2015 as well so who knows
when when abouts will be coming out but
um yeah it'll be cool i think as sean
you're alluding to earlier the more
indie games that microsoft get on this
machine the better yeah absolutely and
limbo was a product of like 2009 back
when there still were all those summer
of arcade games and they still had a
pretty good relationship with indies
before everybody just jumped ship and
went to sony so for them to debut the
new play dead game the guys who made
limbo i think it's a good step forward
uh this is a timed exclusive as well for
the xbox one they said at the end uh
okay then we leaned into the id at xbox
trailer um which had a hell of a bunch
of video games in it in fact
if we're if we're playing we might as
well just go through it right now and
because i have all the the games here
they showed off aztec a couple of ones
we knew about like play gink which is
pretty big on ios um slash dash through
uh but let's see if there's a if they
show off a couple of more of these uh
interesting to show that they're leaning
pretty hard into getting indies on this
bad boy so here's the list of stuff as
tez as that's new to me you guys new to
me as well yeah they've been talking
about it for a little while yeah that's
cool i had a couple packs uh playgink
was really big on ios we played a bunch
of this at gamescom last year
uh white knight
i think i know that one as well i think
that's the it was originally a source
engine game earth lock you know you guys
know that one
this looks so rad very interesting yes
i'm into that
hyper light drifter we played at pax
east and it's fantastic it's great yeah
lifeless panna that's a new one to me as
well this looks really interesting as
well actually
slash dash
never naught noon make sense so connect
right through yeah i saw a demo of this
on pc that's available so i'm not sure
if it's the same developer or not but
that is a thing that's been around
that's cool lovers nadine yeah okay
mighty
mighty number nine ifuna's game the guy
made mega
man it's a new one to me as well grave
another first person horror game yes
hooray threes is coming from the xbox
one
i played this game at pax east it is
basically like a new style super meat
boy game like a tough as nails
platformer it looked really cool
hashtag idarb
let's get it trending
so this is techland these guys made the
dead island games yes and they're making
dying light so it's
interesting to see them in an indie
games compilation
i know i as you know i did not was not a
fan you were not i was not a fan
uh below of course from cappy who've
already had a bit of relationship with
them with id at xbox
sweet okay uh so that's they're sort of
leaning into the indie stuff then we saw
a trailer which could have been anything
i think a couple of people call this one
pretty early yeah the new tomb raider
rise of the tomb raider oh yes my friend
oh yes this is coming holiday 2015. it
is looking pretty sweet i mean it's not
gameplay you know it's all like trailer
stuff but she's talking to a
psychiatrist she runs through the woods
she's got a crossbow there are flares
what more could you possibly want from a
team game got a bear chase scene yeah
right probably the best bear chase i've
seen in the game since condemned two
i like the tone of this they seem to
know what they want to do with this
character yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
this looks sweet right the last human
game was i loved it it was really great
fun so i'm hoping i hope for good things
here like it looks cool for sure so
that's uh the rise of the tomb raider
rise of the dark knight dark knight rise
tomorrow rises after that we saw more it
wasn't so much chasing bears as or being
chased by bears as it was chasing
griffins oh yeah this looks so good
god damn the witcher 3 just look at this
nonsense peter tell me how are your
pants are they wet yet
the girl can jump that's the thing he
can do he can jump
he's got blood trails here
there's there's wenches
yeah what do you think of peter about
how this how this bad boy looks
especially for an xbox one title which
is you know we it's been struggling a
little bit on the graphical front the
guys at cd projekt red obviously are
very smart they know what they're doing
with their engines and uh this just
looks like a really great evolution of
you know the previous witcher games
right it kind of keeps a lot of things
that made it great but they're adding
just just a like a grander experience i
mean i think that's really all that kind
of has to be said here and it does what
any good open world game needs to do
which is provide an interesting visual
design so that you're always compelled
to explore new areas
not every open world game gets that and
that's why not all of them are fun to
explore but this one like just the
different like the swamp environment you
could see as he was like walking in how
moody it got and how it compared to that
green area it looks so good and they
said all the stuff in the background are
places you can actually go to yeah and
then he also takes out his big massive
hmd sword here
oh you're gonna make me use my big boy
sword
yeah so i i feel like the witcher i for
somebody like me who's never played
those games i feel like there's a lot of
hype behind that series yeah from people
who haven't played it uh let's keep
going though next one peter brown you
called this immediately which was
incredible because i didn't have a
goddamn clue what it was phantom dust
explain what the hell is this game
phantom dust is a game for the original
xbox and uh essentially you collect
cards that give your characters
different abilities and you essentially
it's a it's like a mid-air fighting game
with lots of magic
it's
it was a lot of fun it had a great
online multiplayer component back then
which doesn't quite exist anymore
obviously um so this was a very big
surprise for me the guys at grounding
who developed crimson dragon they're
also the team who worked on you know
panzer dragoon uh
at that studio said he always wanted to
go back to the series and was waiting
for permission and this was about last
september last time that was mentioned
so very surprised to see this and i
think this is a great move because for
somebody who doesn't really have a lot
of love for you know the major big
franchises like call of duty and stuff
this is the sort of thing that i find
very different and interesting and fun
to see revealed cool three games left
let's get to them pretty quickly tom
clancy's the division and new content
first on xbox one we saw another demo on
christmas day
you can get xp for
finding out when a toddler died what do
you think about this new video game
still looks really good i mean if
anything like last year i thought it was
a shooter with rpg elements now it looks
like an rpg with shooter elements
because just the sheer
weight of like the xp and like the ui
and all the interface stuff screams rpg
to me are you happy with that because
then the number stuff was what i find
quite irritating the fact that numbers
were coming off them i was like is this
what we're playing now
uh how do you feel about that peter
i think it's an interesting take on the
whole shooter uh trope that you know i
watch watch the tactics oh you're close
door closed confirmed
about uh what do you think about this
mark dude you know you know i was hoping
for something from platinum games this
looks awesome okay i mean that platinum
games are basically the guys that can
nail mechanics in the game like
bayonetta is so sweet just because of
how good it feels to play that game so
i'm hoping something similar here and
talk about the presentation as well i
mean yeah every single game platinum
comes out with they're upping the bar
more and more and it's just it's so
impressive to see i mean obviously this
right here is not gameplay but just some
of the things that i'm willing to expect
after seeing you know even just
bayonetta 2 last year like consider how
much time they've had to spend with
hardware that's more powerful and to
take a game like this where you can sort
of take on super powers you have a
dragon that you work with it's yeah i'm
just really excited and the last
announcement of the day crackdown not
crackdown three just crackdown uh is
coming out i think it's the guys at
claudia doing it uh looks like co-op and
building murder uh sean mcinnes what do
you think it is i'm excited i love the
first crackdown the second one was kind
of a disappointment because it just
stuck to the original so rigidly
and it looks like david jones is back
involved in it he was part of the first
game wasn't involved in the second game
because he was making apb
not so successful
but i yeah as long as they push that
series forward i'm way on board awesome
crackdown rounding up microsoft's press
conference here at e3 2014.
gentlemen we're gonna head off for a
couple of minutes break before we come
back for electronic arts first of all i
want to ask closing thoughts uh mark
walton what did you think about what
microsoft showed today it was nice to
see a lot of games from them you know
i'm not sure it was enough we didn't get
the big
you know flooring announcement that we
all wanted we didn't get that gears of
war moment which i'm kind of
disappointed about but overall pretty
good show yeah bigger mission there i
totally forgot about that peter what are
you thinking from your side honestly i
had zero interest in owning an xbox one
before i'm not gonna lie i actually
after seeing some of these games i can't
wait to buy one and play them really
yeah probably next year but i'm yeah
looking forward to a lot of get that
dead rising three dlc right now it's so
good
sean mckennis what are your thoughts on
it i thought it was good i mean i wasn't
floored by anything but i thought there
was some really great stuff solid b plus
yeah awesome
mark peter sean thank you so much for
joining us on the stage here and we're
going to be back pretty soon with
electronic arts uh the next conference
is on in just under just over half an
hour's time so stick here at
gamespot.com forward slash e3 for more
coverage of the electronic dribble